thanks to indochino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me
look fly right i'm sick to death of
hearing about rights
what about my right not to have my life
work subverted by blind ignorance
that's uh that's not an actual right
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we are covering an
episode of star trek the next generation
it's called
measure of a man it's the episode where
data gets put on trial to determine
whether he is a man
or machine or both i guess it raises all
kinds of
great philosophical and legal questions
are you a person
do you have rights under the u.s
constitution and it tells us that even
in the 24th century where you have
warp drive and teleporters you're still
gonna need
lawyers
as always be sure to hit that bell and
comment in the form of an objection
which i'll either sustain or overrule
and of course stick around until the end
of the video where i give
star trek the next generation measure of
a man a grade for legal realism
so without further ado let's dig in to
measure of a man
explain this procedure ever since i
first saw
data at the entrance evaluation at the
starfleet academy i have wanted to
understand it
i became a student of the works of dr
noni and soon data's creator and
i have tried to continue his work i
believe i am very close to the
breakthrough that will
enable me to duplicate dr soon's work
and replicate this
but as a first step i must disassemble
and study it
data is going to be my guide
so the crux of this episode is that data
is an android he is an artificial form
of life a member of starfleet medical
wants to conduct scientific experiments
on data in the hopes of being able to
replicate the intelligence that forms
data's positronic brain
you've constructed a positronic brain
yes
data doesn't want to do that he thinks
that the starfleet officer
doesn't have the ability to conduct
these experiments safely and captain
picard
isn't willing to give up a member of his
crew to be subjected to these
experiments
so the question is does data have the
autonomy as a
person or a thing that is endowed with
personhood
to be able to reject this request or is
he a thing
that is subject to the whims of
starfleet like
some computer or some machine i think
this episode is meant to hearken back to
some of the darker periods of u.s
history
because the u.s military itself doesn't
have a great track record when it comes
to subjecting
members of the military and sometimes
members of the public to
illegal experimentation you can look at
the tuskegee experiments in world war ii
you can look at the mk-ultra experiments
in the 60s and 70s
unfortunately some people weren't even
asked to be subjected to these magical
experiments so at least
data has the opportunity to defend
himself and the right to a trial
your response is emotional and
irrational irrational you are endowing
data with human characteristics because
it looks human
but it is not if it were a box on wheels
i would not be facing this opposition
overt sentimentality is not one of
captain picard's failings
trust me i know oh snap i will tell you
again
data is a valued member of my crew he's
an outstanding bridge officer
if i am permitted to make this
experiment the horizons for human
achievements become boundless
frankly i think that these questions
probably would have been solved the
moment that data entered into starfleet
you wouldn't let a box on wheels enter
into starfleet academy and go through
all of the different academic training
that is required to enter into starfleet
so realistically speaking i think some
of these questions would have already
been solved but it's interesting to
tackle them now at least
consider every ship in starfleet with
the data
on board utilizing its extraordinary
capabilities
acting as our hands and eyes in
dangerous situations
like you're preaching to the choir here
why don't you get to the point
it's a classic ends justify the means uh
argument there
data must not be permitted to resign
data is a star fleet officer he still
has certain rights
right right i'm sick to death of hearing
about rights what about my right not to
have my life work
subverted by blind ignorance that's uh
that's not an actual
right we have rule of law in this
federation you cannot simply seize
people and experiment with them to prove
your pet theories
thank you now you're doing it yeah
generally speaking that would be right
data is an extraordinary piece of
engineering but it is a machine
if you permitted to resign it will
destroy years of work and robotics
starfleet does not have to allow the
resignation commander who do you think
you're working for
starfleet is not an organization that
ignores its own regulations when they
become inconvenient
whether you like it or not data does
have rights
that is sort of the rule of law in a
nutshell the point is
that the laws that we have should be
universal and applied to
everyone they should not be changed on a
whim and
given ad hoc exemptions based on
philosophical justifications like the
ends justifying the means a lot of
people talk about the first amendment
right to freedom of speech but at the
same time they complain when they hear
people use speech in ways that they
don't like but the point is that it's a
universal right and that
maybe there would be more beneficial
outcomes but
the point is that individual rights
cannot be subverted
based on whim or based on circumstance
they're supposed to be universal
let me put it another one
would you permit the computer of the
enterprise to refuse a refit
that's an interesting point but the
enterprise computer is property
is data of course
there may be law to support this
position then find it
a ruling with such broad-ranging
implications must be supported
yeah so that would be generally correct
a computer
is uh movable property in other words
it's what we call chattel and in fact
in my analysis of the sokovia accords in
the marvel universe
i made an offhand joke that vision is
really just a computer and
therefore vision was chattel to
tony stark data is a toaster i don't
think it's that simple
but the same arguments could apply here
and odds are there's not going to be
specific legislation out there that says
a computer
of specific intelligence is considered a
person
with respect to all of the
constitutional rights that
are endowed to actual human people but
that is sort of the point of
some of this case law is that when there
is a new
example out there you have to actually
go through a trial to determine what the
rights are
i have completed my research based on
the acts of cumberland passed in the
early 21st century
data is the property of starfleet he
cannot resign and he cannot refuse to
cooperate with commander maddox
i would very much like to see the
language that is used in the acts of
cumberland
that she's referring to i guess maybe i
have to stand corrected on my prior
statement about
there being legislation that deals with
whether a computer
is uh sufficiently human to constitute a
person under the constitution but that
being said this is actually reminiscent
of the dred scott versus sanford
decision
in 1857. that was the landmark supreme
court decision
that held that the constitution did not
include citizenship
for black americans regardless of
whether they were enslaved or
free and therefore the rights and
privileges that citizenship confers on
american citizens
would never apply to black americans the
plaintiff in that case was a man named
dred scott who
was a slave at the time and whose owners
took him from missouri which was a slave
state
into the missouri territory most of
which had been designated as
free by the missouri compromise in when
scott's owners took him back
to missouri he sued in court claiming
that because he had been taken into a
free u.s territory
he had automatically been freed been
conferred with the rights of an american
citizen
and was no longer a slave in a decision
that remained a blight on the
record of the us supreme court for years
they ruled that the constitution simply
did not apply to african americans so in
essence data is going to go through a
similar trial here
what if i challenge this ruling then i
shall be required to hold a hearing
then i so challenge convene your hearing
convene your hearing
captain that would be exceedingly
difficult
this is a new base i have no staff
but surely captain you have regulations
to
take care of such an eventuality or just
make new law
i can use serving officers as legal
counsel
you as the senior officer would defend
very good and the unenviable task of
prosecuting this case would fall on you
commander as the next most senior
officer of the defendant's ship
i can't i won't date is my comrade we
have served together
i not only respect him i consider him my
friend
when people of good conscience have an
honest dispute we must still
sometimes resort to this kind of
adversarial system you just want me to
prove that data
is a mere machine i can't do that
because i don't believe it
i happen to know better so i am neither
qualified nor willing
i'm gonna have to find someone else then
i will rule summarily based on my
findings
yeah so that doesn't work for a couple
of reasons number one
a lawyer has to be a zealous advocate
for
his or her client so if you strongly
believe
that you cannot put forth a good defense
or good prosecution ethically i think
you are unable to fulfill the task and i
think you need to step aside
additionally it would be completely
improper for the judge to rule
in an ad hoc basis that just because a
lawyer refuses to
prosecute the case to then rule against
the defense that would be a huge
violation of the rights
of the defendant which i think you have
to assume that data
gets the benefit of the doubt at least
in the first instance that
he is a person a member of starfleet and
entitled to certain rights
verified lieutenant commander data so
should point out that as a defendant you
always want to put your best foot
forward
and wearing a yellow one-piece bodysuit
to court
is not the best way to dress for court
indochi
who built you commander dr noonian soon
and he was the foremost authority on
cybernetics
more basic than that what was he
human thank you
commander what is the capacity of your
memory and how fast can you access
information
i have an ultimate storage capacity of
800 quadrillion bits
my total linear computational speed has
been rated at 60 trillion operations per
second
your honor i offered evidence
prosecutions exhibit a
a rod of par steel tensile strength 40
kilobars
all right that's a pretty reasonable way
to add something
into evidence i think he probably should
have laid some more foundation
since he's not an expert in types of
steel
or the tensile strength of steel but at
least he entered it into evidence before
having the witness talk about it which
is actually
something that a lot of legal dramas
actually forget to do
so that part was reasonably accurate of
course the judge
forgot to rule on the motion to add that
piece of steel
into evidence in court you actually have
to say
the thing that you're doing you can't
just nod because the stenographer can't
actually take
down nod so the judge sort of said yes
motion to enter the bar of steel into
evidence is granted so that is actually
reflected in the record
commander would you bend that objection
there are many life forms possessed with
mega strength
his issues are not relevant to this
hearing i'm afraid i can't agree captain
proceed with your demonstration
commander yeah that's not a great
objection and it was a good ruling by
the judge here
essentially what captain picard was
doing is saying that
it's not going to prove the ultimate
issue
but his objection is going to the weight
of the particular evidence
not the admissibility you can enter
things into evidence even if they have
only a tenuous relation to
the ultimate issue in this case whether
data is human or not
it helps prove or disprove the idea that
he is
human or property so captain picard was
wrong to object just because
it's not as persuasive as riker thinks
it is
so that it should not be entered into
evidence that is a question for the
trier of fact to decide
and that's why the judge overruled his
objection because it goes to the weight
not the admissibility of that particular
piece of evidence
drawing on the log of the construction
the prototype android lore
also constructed by nuni and soon a
request to be allowed
to remove the commander's hand for your
inspection objection
you should probably state your grounds
doesn't matter
uh withdrawal okay not sure what the
objection would have been
christine commander
i'm sorry
[Music]
the commander is a physical
representation of a dream
an idea conceived of by the mind of a
man
here riker is just lapsing into argument
which you're not allowed to do while
you're in the middle of
examining a witness there are examples
where you can conduct
a physical examination of a witness
which is effectively what riker has done
you might recall that in the o.j simpson
trial there was a big deal made about
o.j simpson's ability or inability to
wear
a glove that was found at the scene of
the crime
if it doesn't fit you must acquit and
effectively riker has done something
similar here
in terms of removing data's hand you
generally
don't want to do that because you don't
know exactly how it's going to go
but here it's fairly safe because riker
knew that he could remove
data's hand without much fuss and that's
exactly what he did
the problem is that he is lapsing
straight into argument effectively his
closing argument
while in the middle of asking data
questions and doing a physical
examination
that you are not allowed to do and
picard should be objecting here
its purpose to serve human needs
and interests argumentation of neural
nets
ask a question rustic algorithms
it's responses dictated by an elaborate
software written
by a man it's hardware built by a man
and now and now a man will shut it off
[Music]
so the point is well taken that shutting
off data means he's not
actual human life although you could
argue that riker just committed murder
because
he turned data off the bigger problem
from a trial lawyer perspective is that
he is engaging in
argument while he should be questioning
data
pinocchio is broken you're broken
strings have been cut
more argument fonder riker has
dramatically demonstrated to this court
that lieutenant commander data is a
machine
do we deny that no because it is not
relevant
we too are machines just machines of a
different
type commander riker has also
reminded us that lieutenant commander
data was created by a human
do we deny that no again it is not
relevant
so this is good despite the fact that
this is total argument that you would
normally save for a closing argument or
a motion before the court
i like what captain picard is doing here
which is that he is admitting
to the things that are sort of optically
bad for his case
that data is a machine that data was
created by another person
one of the things that you want to do
whether it is a bench trial or a jury
trial
is limit the number of issues you
actually have to dispute so that is a
great tactic by
captain picard and actually one of the
rhetorical devices that i use
in my motions on occasion is i will
state what the opposing side has argued
and i will say
that is as true as it is irrelevant i
call to the standard come on to bruce
maddox as a hostile witness
so you don't actually get to call
certain witnesses to the stand
as hostile witnesses a hostile witness
is a real thing that is not just
something you see on tv
what that means is that you have called
that person as a witness to the stand so
essentially you are asking them to be
subject to a direct examination
and as you may have heard in tv you're
not allowed to ask leading questions
of a witness that you have called to the
stand
leading questions are totally okay for
cross-examination but they are they're
not okay for direct examination so you
are asking the judge to recognize that
although it's direct examination
the witness is quote hostile and
therefore you should be able to ask
leading questions on direct examination
but you don't get to just
call them to the stand and say that
they're hostile is your contention that
lieutenant commander data is not a
sentient being
and that we're not entitled to all the
rights reserved for
all life forms within this federation
data is not
sentient no god would you enlighten us
what is required for sentience
intelligence self-awareness
consciousness
prove to the court that i am sentient
this is absurd
we all know you're sentient so i am
sentient but commander data is not
that's right why
why am i sentient well you are
self-aware
ah that's the second of your criteria
let's deal with the first
intelligence so as a
tangent here this is a huge question not
only in the law
which doesn't really answer the question
but also in philosophy
in neurology there are tons of different
definitions of sentience of intelligence
of consciousness
of the theory of the mind and there's
really no good way of being able to
prove
that someone or something is sentient
but with
any definition that you're going to run
across you're going to have problems of
over-inclusiveness
and under-inclusiveness so it's hard not
to feel bad for maddox here because it
is one of the hardest questions in
not only philosophy but neurology as
well is commander data
intelligent yes it has the ability to
learn and understand and to
cope with new situations like this
hearing yes
what about self-awareness what does that
mean
why why am i self-aware
because you are conscious of your
existence and actions
you are aware of yourself and your own
ego
come on today to what you're doing now
i'm taking part in a legal hearing to
determine my rights and status
am i a person or property and what's at
stake
my right to choose perhaps my very life
so rhetorically it's great to uh
turn to data and ask him a question that
totally destroys the statement that the
witness just made but you are not
allowed to
ask questions of another person while
you're in the middle of a direct
examination of another witness it
doesn't
work that way regardless of how dramatic
it seems it's totally improper
now sooner or later this man or others
like him will succeed in replicating
commander data
now the decision you reach here today
will determine how we will regard this
creation of our genius it will reveal
the kind of a people we are
what he is destined to be it will reach
far beyond this courtroom and this
one android generally you're not
supposed to make these kind of arguments
this is
sort of like captain picard's closing
argument here and you are
you're meant to adjudicate the facts of
the case before you
and generally speaking the judge or the
jury or the the trier effect
is not meant to consider
the the far-reaching implications you
are simply supposed to
apply the facts to the law of the case
at hand and that's sort of the
doctrine of judicial minimalism that you
don't want people making broad
pronouncements you want them to
adjudicate
just the smallest thing they possibly
can based on the case that is before
them
it could significantly redefine the
boundaries of personal liberty and
freedom expanding them for some
savagely curtailing them for others
can you prepare to condemn him and all
who come after him to servitude and
slavery
your honor starfleet was founded to seek
out new life
and new civilizations to boldly go
where no lawyer has gone before well
there it sits
waiting
you wanted a chance to make law well
here it is make it a good one
all right and starfleet decides that
data is in fact a person
and has rights under whatever the
equivalent of the starfleet constitution
is does data have a soul i don't know
that he has
but i have got to give him the freedom
to explore that question himself
[Music]
but how realistic was it well now it's
time to give
star trek the next generation the
measure of a man episode of grade for
legal realism
on the one hand you have obviously a lot
of dramatic license taken
they are trying to decide these heady
issues from a
member of the judge advocate general
that's trying to make new law
in a way that is sort of a kangaroo
court condensed for 40 minutes on tv on
the other hand
you have some reasonable things going on
you've got someone who is treated as a
hostile witness
you have reasonable arguments being made
a couple good objections
and some good rulings by the court so i
give this episode of star trek the next
generation
a c plus they boldly went where they
were supposed to go
good try nine out of ten for effort now
if data was my client the first thing
that i would have him do is get a proper
suit to wear to court
frankly a yellow one-piece bodysuit is
not proper
court attire if you are looking for a
proper court attire i can't recommend
indochino
highly enough all of my suits are now
custom made by indochino i buy them with
my own money and i love them so much
that i reached out personally to them
and i'm thrilled that they're now a
sponsor of this channel the secret to
a great suit is all about fit i'm a
reasonably athletic guy
and i can never buy suits off the rack
because they never
fit right is that vanity indochino will
make you a fully custom suit tailored
specifically to you for less than
dollars the best part is they still use
the best materials like super 140 wool
and cashmere frankly i will never buy an
off-the-rack suit again and the same
goes for their custom dress shirts
so you can avoid the dreaded muffin top
or the
brooks brothers special as i like to
call it you can either send your
measurements in
online or you can go to a store and have
a stylist take your measurements which
is what i did
my personal stylist andrew took all of
my measurements and a couple of weeks
later i got the best fitting suit of my
entire life it was perfect
right out of the box legal eagles can
get any premium indochino suit for just
379 dollars when you enter the code
legaleagle at checkout
or use the link in the description
clicking on the link
really helps out the channel that's
indochino.com
promo code legaleagle for the best
custom suit of your life
it sounds intriguing do you agree with
my grade do you think data
is a person or a machine leave your
objections in the comments
and check out this playlist of all my
other real lawyer reactions over here
where i will see you in court